-Let me start by thanking you
for being here
and also congratulating you.
Your wife gave birth
three days ago!
-She did.
-Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm a very, very,
very proud father.
-I gotta say.
-Yeah. As well you should be.
-This was your second?
-My second.
-So, I'm about to have
my second any day now, really,
and I have to say --
Was the experience the same
or did you feel like a pro
being in there the second time?
-Pbbht.
I mean -- Oh, I mean --
45 minutes
my wife took to deliver.
-Yeah.
-And it was incredible.
The nurses
were just extraordinary,
and I was in a state of shock.
I mean, I really was.
-I only hope I can be as useless
as I was last time.
No, really,
I was sending texts.
And then the nurse -- When they
measured her cervix, they said,
"We're at 9. We're going."
"We're what?"
You know, it was like --
Literally.
-By the way, even at 8,
you shouldn't be texting.
-[ Laughs ] But that was the
first measurement they took.
-Oh, oh, I got it.
-It was the first measurement.
We were there taking it easy,
and then it was like,
"We're 9."
I was just like,
"Oh. Whoa. Okay."
-Well, that's great.
And was it a boy, girl?
What'd you have?
-A boy.
-A little boy.
You have another little boy,
as well, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's very exciting.
And may I just say
thank you to your family
for letting you be here tonight.
I really appreciate it.
-Thanks, guys, really.
Papa really is working, James.
I'm actually...
-I know it looks like
Papa's just talking to a man.
-Well, my son, my son
doesn't know what I'm doing.
He says,
"Where are you going, Papa?"
You know, somebody comes
to pick me up again.
And I --
"It's two sleeps, two sleeps."
-Oh, that -- You mean
you'll see him in two sleeps?
-Yeah.
-That's wonderful.
-So if you're still up watching,
here I am.
-[ Laughs ] There you go.
"This is the bad man
who took your father!"
-It's him, it's him, it's him!
-So, I want to ask,
how much did you know,
one, about the Kennedys,
and, two, about
this specific moment,
this Chappaquiddick moment,
before this movie?
-Well, I'm like most people.
I thought I knew a lot.
Like everybody, I thought
I knew a lot about the Kennedys.
I thought I knew
about American politics.
about this incident.
But then
when I read that script
and then I got off the plane
and checked the facts,
I realized how little
I did know.
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
I couldn't believe some of the
things I'd read in the script,
such as, you know,
the asphyxiation
or, you know, lack of air
rather than drowning.
-Well, it's funny. I just --
I do want to explain, because
I think you had this moment
happen at the premiere,
where you realize
a lot of younger people
don't know about this moment
where Ted Kennedy
drove off a bridge.
There was a women in the car.
He survived. She didn't.
And this film kind of
covers the days after
and his pretty terrible behavior
in the moments
after this accident happened.
-Yeah, his behavior,
I mean, society's behavior.
I mean, you know,
he not only got away with it,
but he also managed to thrive
and also went on to do a great
many wonderful, amazing things
in terms of the legislation
that he passed,
and contribute to society.
But, yes, he got away with it,
you know, and we elected him.
-And we talk now --
You know, obviously,
I think the thing we're
talking about a lot right now
is what people in politics are
getting away with right now.
It's like nothing
we've ever seen before.
And it does strike me that
current generations forget
that people have been
getting away with things.
And not just people
in the Republican party,
but people in the
Democratic party, as well,
with terrible behavior.
-Yeah.
-And did you find, like,
when you screened this --
Because I know one of the
taglines for the film is
"This really happened."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Because people
might not believe
that this was a thing
that someone got away with.
-It's true. I mean,
things are pretty crazy now,
but 1968, you know --
Martin Luther King. 50 years.
He was shot.
Bobby Kennedy was shot.
There were race riots.
There was a Vietnam War.
I mean, these are crazy days.
But I think
it's always important
to put things in context
and perspective
and learn from history
and understand
that, you know what,
we've been through tough times.
With the right people, with
the right thought and education
and votes and belief,
we can make better days.